back in 2007 inventor and entrepreneur
steve jobs revolutionized the cell phone
market with the release of the apple
iphone perhaps the most iconic invention
of the 21st century this new device
caused people to rethink just what a
phone could be and set the stage for the
mobile technology to come over the
following years with all its early
success the dominance of the iphone is
still going strong apple is currently on
its 13th iteration of the iphone and
various iphone models make up the top
three selling phones of 2021 but even
with their continued success and loyal
user base how does apple square up
against their number one rival samsung
today we're going to take a look at the
two tech giants and see who comes out on
top
the tech for years the hottest debate on
the smartphone market has been between
the apple iphone and samsung's galaxy
series the lines hotly divided consumers
and industry experts alike in 2021 the
competition between the iphone and the
galaxy continues with apple selling
their iphone 13 models and samsung
unveiling the samsung galaxy s21 so how
do the two phones square up to one
another design
both models currently on the market are
noteworthy for their sleek and
attractive design features the iphone 13
is available in five colors including a
new pink option whereas the s21 comes in
four colors that possess an iridescent
quality to the casting the iphone 13 pro
max and the samsung galaxy s21 ultra are
both known for having some of the
largest displays of any mainstream
smartphones the iphone max and s21 ultra
models are both pretty huge in size
measuring 6.7 and 6.8 inches with the
s21 ultra beating out the iphone max by
just 0.1 of an inch samsung's s21 ultra
provides users with a higher resolution
along with a screen to body ratio of
almost 90 percent the screen's peak
brightness is a whopping 1300 nits and
the s21 ultra makes samsung's first
model to sport a variable refresh rate
maxing out at 120 hertz the incredibly
high refresh rate of the s21 makes it an
absolute dream for seamless rendering
and high speed gameplay the iphone on
the other hand loses out when it comes
to peak brightness falling short of
samsung's 1300 nits by around 100 nits
less peak brightness the iphone
technically also sports a lower
resolution than the s21's display
although the difference is so
microscopic it would be impossible to
tell with a naked eye
cameras for many people
the quality of the two phones cameras is
what will draw them to buy one over the
other camera quality is one of the major
ways that both manufacturers use to
showcase their technological
improvements and prove their progress
and when we look at the camera models of
both apple and samsung the quality of
the camera technology is truly
remarkable the apple iphone 13 pro max
sports a 12 megapixel camera and a wide
lens of 26 millimeters the camera also
offers a 77 millimeter telephoto range
and three times optical zoom even more
impressive than this is the iphone 13
millimeter 120 degree ultra wide camera
that offers stunning wide shots that
could honestly belong on a movie screen
the iphone boasts so many camera
features including cinematic mode pro
raw pro res tons of effects and the
ability to edit an incredible detail
it's pretty much safe to say that this
camera can do all of the work of a dslr
and still fit in your jeans pocket while
the iphone was once the undisputed king
when it came to their cameras the camera
features of the samsung s21 ultra match
up to the iphone pretty evenly if not
better the s21 models have an extra
camera in comparison to the iphone 13.
the s21's camera maintains galaxy's top
reputation for their incredible zoom
capacities with the times 3 hybrid
optical zoom and 30 times digital zoom
it's more versatile than what's offered
on the apple iphone the lenses of the
s21 face up nicely to the iphone 13
sporting 24 millimeter wide 240
millimeter periscope telephoto 72
millimeter telephoto and 13 millimeter
ultra wide options when it comes to the
winner here it's a matter of preference
while the s21 has more mechanical might
the iphone's camera features are more
intelligent in design meaning that the
choice comes down to what you intend to
do with your camera battery life
the battery life on both models is truly
impressive with iphone 13 pro max
offering 4 352 milliamp hour 27 watt
fast charging that reaches a capacity of
50 percent in 30 minutes the iphone uses
both magsafe 15 watt wireless charging
and 7.5 watt qi wireless charging which
may just take the edge over galaxy's s21
ultra's 5 000 milliamp hour and 25 watt
fast charging so between apple and
samsung the competition on their
flagship products is still pretty tight
although the apple iphone continues to
outsell its samsung counterpart
startup versus conglomerate while apple
and samsung now compete as two mega
giants of tech production the origins of
both companies differ greatly from one
another apple was famously founded in
1976 by two college dropouts steve jobs
and steve wozniak the two developers
were united by a unique vision for the
future of personal technology since
bringing desktop computing into the
mainstream in 1994 apple has since gone
on to reinvent other areas of life with
the release of the ipod iphone and ipad
samsung on the other hand has had a
journey filled with far more twists and
turns before it became the tech
megacorporation we know it as today
samsung was founded in 1938 in south
korea by the south korean businessman
libyan chul according to lee the name
samsung means three stars which
symbolizes something powerful and
everlasting the company started out as a
general trading company buying and
selling goods that ranged from processed
food to textiles and later diversified
into insurance securities and retail
throughout the 1960s samsung began
entering the electronics market and by
1980 they were already making strides in
telecommunications throughout the 21st
century samsung set their sights on
dominating the mobile phone market and
as soon as they did it didn't take long
for tensions to boil between the two
rivals in 2012 apple demanded 2.5
billion us dollars from samsung in
damages for the supposed violation of
six apple patents on smartphone
technology a jury of nine americans
ruled that samsung would indeed have to
pay apple for damages on patent
violation but only 1.05 billion us
dollars out of the 2.5 they requested
this first skirmish caused samsung's
stock value to drop dramatically and led
to apple requesting a total ban on eight
models of samsung phones a request that
was denied by the us court the two
manufacturers have been going head to
head ever since with consumers often
taking sides built on extreme loyalty
rarely switching from one manufacturer
to the other who's richer
while apple and samsung are both among
the top 20 richest companies in the
world when it comes to overall revenue
apple takes the cake apple stands as the
sixth highest grossing company in the
entire world this means that things are
going well for apple as this figure
currently stands as their highest ever
reported revenue samsung may not be
making as much as apple but their
revenue is still pretty mind-blowing in
2021 the company reported an annual
revenue of about 200 billion us dollars
although this revenue was made up of
their diverse range of electronic goods
what's even more impressive about this
figure is that it accounts for a
whopping 17 percent of south korea's
overall gdp in fact samsung is
responsible for one-fifth of the exports
that come from south korea each year
when it comes to profits apple again
stands as the clear winner in the 2020
financial year the makers of the iphone
reported net profits of 57 billion us
dollars in comparison the profits
generated by samsung sales were just
over 30 billion these profits are
reflected in the net worth of the two
companies while samsung possesses an
impressive market cap of 510 billion us
dollars apple's total market cap of 2021
currently stands at a mind-boggling 2.25
trillion u.s dollars this makes apple
the single largest company in the world
by market cap alone what's more over the
2020 financial year apple enjoyed modest
growth of three percent while samsung
saw its growth fall by 14
so when it comes to talking apple is 100
dominating over samsung in the global
market company values both manufacturers
have come under fire numerous times for
problems along their supply chains and
possible exploitation of assembly line
workers overseas over the past years
both apple and samsung have sought to
improve their public image by promoting
sustainable supply chain practices apple
has been leading the way for tech
companies in its use of sustainable
energy with their aim being to
manufacture using only renewable or
recycled materials as of 2021 the
company itself remains carbon neutral
and aims for all of its products to also
be carbon neutral by the year 2030.
samsung on the other hand continued to
meet its 2020 target of renewable energy
usage across all work sites in the us
china and europe throughout 2021. both
samsung and apple have strong corporate
cultures and promote themselves as
innovative and sustainable powerhouses
for the future who's better
apple and samsung may go head-to-head
with one another on the smartphone
market but each manufacturer has their
own areas in which they dominate who do
you think is the true market leader in
2021 are you more of a samsung fan or
are you a die-hard apple user let us
know in the comments section and be sure
to check out the rest of the channel for
more insights into the world of tech